when you start thinking about the
structure of a story key beats
turning points you know i think um
i think you need to keep a reader
engaged i don't think there is a
set time but if you're you know 15 18
20 25 30 pages in and we still have no
idea what's going on
or there hasn't been that you know
moment
i i think you kind of need to rethink
some things
you know there's the old saying when you
watch a movie it's that 42 to 46 minute
point that usually
kind of becomes a slow burn no matter
what the movie is so i know a lot of
writers and filmmakers try to make sure
that point of the film
doesn't lack a spark or an interest
because that's a lot of times where
people
they're not going to give up on the film
but they tend to get a little restless
it seems a lot of people take a really
long time to get to the point and i
think and i've learned that
as a independent filmmaker when you sell
your material
it's more about you know we have to
remember this as a business and now in
days with phones and tablets and
distractions and
pets and kids and everything else under
the sun going on
we're constantly interrupted audiences
when they see your film
unless they're really at a movie theater
and truly turn their phones off
are never really 100 immersed in your
story
there's always something there's a noise
outside
there's a cat knocking over a vase it's
a kid who's crying because he didn't get
his way and he's hungry and
you know you have to realize that as a
filmmaker
what you're up against and i think
to just kind of lull along to tell your
story it's very rare that you're going
to be
able to compete with anything so i think
to be able to throw some twists and
turns
to engage your audience into some new
layers or elements or characters
or what's the point of this movie a
little sooner than we used to
i think is happening needs to happen
more often and i think a lot of writers
are starting to figure that out
so then you wouldn't be working some of
this out in the treatment stage
it's once you actually start the actual
screenwriting process
i've gotten to the point now when i work
with writers i tell them it's gotta you
know it's it's
sadly um there's kind of an 11 minute
rule
abroad that we kind of need to know what
this is about
what's going on what we're signing up
for in the first 11 minutes of the
actual movie
which is going to tell somebody that's
got to happen in the first 12 to 15
pages of the script
and i don't like telling stories that
way but i've also learned the hard way
i've had some
some projects that you know hey
if you do this it'll sell hey if you
change this it will
it will move and what i've learned is
the faster we get to the point in our
storytelling and i know this goes
against
everything from telling great stories of
the old days but we're living in a new
time
and it has really gotten to be about
get to the frickin point what am i
signing up for early
they they want to know it's like you
know give you an example in the film
that i just did that's coming out break
even
it's about four kids who find 50 million
dollars while
scuba diving at a remote island and we
developed this opening
and this whole thing and this back story
and why are these kids here and who are
they and what's their relationships
and it was basically yeah we need to
find out
50 million dollars by 12 minutes in it's
like well wait a minute that doesn't
come in until page 30. well
it needs to come in about 12 minutes in
so you
you have to restructure some things you
have to cut scenes you have to cut
backstory because at the end of the day
when you're selling a movie around the
world
they're signing up for something and if
you're selling an action film if you're
selling a thriller if you're selling a
suspense story
you better get to it because there's too
much competition there's too many things
that are moving
fast that'll hold attention because it
moves so fast that's what that mtv
generation
of cutting came from is we don't know
how to tell a good story so we're going
to cut a bunch of stuff really fast so
you're afraid to take your eyes off the
screen
and that has now become it's found its
way i think it's found a balance and
storytelling with films a little better
but we need to get to the point
and if you look at the older films uh
some of the most of the ones that i grew
up you know cherry it's a fire the black
stallion you know all these
enchanting april you're looking like 25
28 35 minutes in until you really kind
of have an idea
if you watch the black stallion they
don't in introduce
mickey mickey rooney's character until
about
i think 48 minutes in you know the kids
alone at the island for 30 minutes are
crying out loud then he gets home and
then he's got to reintegrate in school
and then all of a sudden the horse runs
away and then
he goes on this trip to try to find the
horse and then there's your co-star
and it was also that way with on golden
pond they didn't bring
you know jane fonda in until 25 minutes
in
so i don't think those play as much
anymore um
not saying the films don't hold up is
great cinema but
we want to meet the players we want to
know what the game is a lot quicker now
or even the stepford wives like i mean
that was the like the original
the original one yeah i mean just long
driving scenes with the music the
soundtrack
yeah there was something comforting
about that i don't know if that would
work today
well you know quentin did it in once
upon a time in hollywood i think he
really exploited the driving scenes but
we're looking at the back of brad pitt
and leonardo dicaprio's head so you know
that makes it a little different but
what i try to tell the independent
filmmakers if you're not getting brad or
leo as your stars and i don't even get
them as my stars
um your your international buyers want
to get to the point
and we're at a point now where we you
know we are able to lock picture
and we don't make different cuts for
different markets or parts of the globe
we've kind of learned that
what what works comfortably everywhere
you know there's 54 territories that we
sell to around the globe 100 what is it
170 countries
and in that you you have 54 territories
and you want to try to do something
that's going to appeal to everybody and
it's hard to please all the people all
the time but getting to the point
quickly is one that you can really help
sell that movie a lot better
if people know what they're signing up
for in the first 15 20 minutes tops
well it's interesting because people
seem to get upset when we say
that or we interview people and they say
you know if a script isn't good by 10
pages in
most people will stop reading it and so
then the comments are well
you're not giving it a chance right
people just don't have the patience
anymore you know again i hate to revert
to it you go back to i mean look at
close encounters of the third kind
brilliant film that is a slow burn yeah
i think if that movie was made today
that would be a lot different
not taking anything away from steven who
did a great job writing the script it
was based on
an experience he had as a kid and a
great job directing it but you're gonna
tell me that movie today would play at
that pace
i don't think so and you're right a lot
of people you're not giving it a chance
and most readers will say god if it
doesn't get me by page eight i'm done
i think you kind of have to you know the
executives
you know there was a trend where all the
executives are saying you got to find
that hook it's got to be edgy you know i
wanted to be edgy and grab me you know
shake me by my
buy my lapels by page eight you know and
so everybody came up with the edgy crazy
opening that just shocked everybody
i don't think i don't think shock and
awe is what make people watch a whole
movie
people want to be drawn in they want to
care about characters they want to go
along for a journey and they know what
they're signing up for but you have to
make that journey interesting you want
to put some bends in the road
you want to have some interesting things
that they're going to pass and i think
you need to occasionally give them a
flat tire
throw a rod in the engine they're going
to have to get out grab their bags
hitchhike find a ride
you know i think i just think that's
where we are now people are just so
bored i mean you look at twitter twitter
has an auto feed now
i don't even i can't even go on it
anymore because the second i try to read
what somebody tweeted it automatically
scrolls
and i can't find the tweet i was reading
and there's no way to stop that that's
just how we're getting our information
now
and there's we got to find a balance in
storytelling
but that is kind of what what's working
right now
and it's frustrating it's a hard pace to
keep up with
you